hello my name is Peter Lacey I'm the
managing director of sustainability
services Accenture and I'm going to
tackle a question submitted by Lewis any
from Brazil and there is any ask what do
we need to be doing to try better
education on this sustainability on the
environment so there's any I think
that's a great question I think it's at
the heart of a lot of the conversations
that I've been having here at Davos I
think there are two important
constituencies from an educational
perspective the first constituency is
really business education and students
and university students and the second
is consumers so let's go first to your
students I think one of the things that
we need to be doing on the environment
is to make sure that sustainable
business is really the default for mbas
for executive education so that we are
educating and building the knowledge and
the skills and the attitudes of the next
generation of managers that means
getting into curricula that means
getting it into research programs and
really making sure that we are
developing leaders fit for purpose for
the future and as a really a call to
action for many universities and many
educational establishments and
particularly business schools around the
world the second constituency as assays
consumers or customers I think that one
of the most interesting insights early
this week was a breakfast I had with 30
CEOs from the consumer goods industry
and those CEOs were discussing report
that the World Economic Forum worked on
with my team at accenture which looked
at how to scale sustainability in
consumer goods and it looks at how you
shape supply and supply side initiatives
for example things like Forest
Stewardship Council in looked at shaping
policy incentives of shaping regulation
and government interventions and but
then also it looked at consumers and one
of the clear takeaways was that the
consumer still doesn't necessarily
understand sustainability that we've got
a long way to go before sustainability
is fraying
a way that really matters to consumers
and so I think for me that's the other
area that we need to work on and that
requires companies to think through how
to use their marketing makes how to use
their brands how to use many of the
channels that are emerging such as
digital media social media to make
sustainable business just doing business